the last week was a great experience a
temperature of 38.5 for i don't know how
many days fatigue and no social networks
total isolation almost mystical i would
say however it was in that moment of
febrile delirium that i asked myself i
wonder if there are peoples in the world
as isolated as the sick simone locked up
in his bedroom well they exist they are
also many
[Music]
it's hard to know how many uncontacted
tribes exist today according to the
research group survival international
that number would be more than 100
worldwide the names of those known
tribes are exotic and often
unpronounceable
mascopiro kawahiba ayureo yanomami
toromona kolubu tagaeri korowai asmat
just to mention a dozen of them
a tribe can be said to be uncontacted
when four factors exist
self-sufficiency in food typical of
untogether people
geographic remoteness
poor technological level equal to that
of peoples who never went through the
bronze or iron age and finally reduced
immunity to diseases translated a cold
of hours can kill them
now some of you may remember the us
missionary john allen chao who was
killed in 2018 by the indigenous people
of the creepy sentinel island of the
andaman islands in india
here john in his mission of religious
conversion made a great mistake of
underestimation perhaps the legacy of
the myth of the good savage one must
first understand that defining these
tribes as uncontacted can be misleading
it's impossible to avoid contact with
outsiders altogether even just an
unwanted sighting can undo their total
isolation sure tenacity refusing even
violently contact with the quote-unquote
outside world is an aspect that unites
these tribes it may also be that some of
them had dealings with outsiders in the
past and that because of the violence of
the settlers they have decided to keep
away from shall we say civilized men
there are civilized but we shall see
that we may not be so civilized as
people it may also be that other tribes
have never had any interest in being
approached but undoubtedly the factor
that plays into the isolation of all
these tribes is geography these peoples
live in remote and hardly explorable
corners of the planet the amazon the
forests of new guinea congo or islands
scattered in the ocean all places where
even livingston would have given up
venturing in the case of new guinea the
region of west papua in indonesia is
believed to be home to more than 40
indigenous groups that have never been
contacted this time part of the island
papua new guinea is also home to
hundreds of tribes but unlike the
indonesian west these tribes live more
or less in open contact with
civilization
in the congo beijing in the heart of
africa home to the world's second
largest rainforest after the amazon live
debaca a group there is suffering land
theft and murder by the berry park
rangers who in reality should be
protecting the rights even more isolated
are those people who live on the atolls
at one time australia or rather oceania
as a continent was that area of the
world that boasted the largest number of
indigenous people ever to come into
contact with modernity
the australian aborigines met british
colonization in the late 18th century
and since then the last virgin tribe to
come out of the enclosure of peoples
never contacted was the pin2p9
aborigines in the northern territory
in 1984 the pintupi were officially the
last tribe on the oceanic continent to
come out of complete isolation at
present at least based on what we know
the only island group that avoids any
contact with the rest of the world is
the well-known sentinelese
[Music]
north sentinel island is located in the
andaman archipelago which is under the
jurisdiction of the indian government
but a clarification must be made in the
andamans the sentinelese are not the
only isolated indigenous group there's
also the arawas who reside on the
western coast of the andamans and have
been decimated by the constant safaris
organized by private tourist companies
north sentinel on the other hand is a
peculiar case in its own right they hate
safaris and do not allow themselves to
be approached suffice it to say for now
that india has established a three
kilometers per meter around the island
to prevent ships fishing boats and
unwary tourists from approaching there
have been very few encounters between
foreigners and locals all on the beach
and never in sight with shipwrecked
fishermen and murdered adventurers
according to a study in the american
journal of human genetics the
sentinelese are said to be related to
other indigenous groups in the andaman
islands and share the same asian
ancestry with them however nothing is
known about their language and indian
authorities have only rough estimates of
the number of inhabitants perhaps around
200. at the time of the tsunami that hit
southeast asia in 2004 the indian
government sent a helicopter to check on
the tribe's situation the helicopter was
greeted with a bow and arrow and a clear
message
you are not welcome here we don't want
you but as mentioned the sentinelese are
more unique than rare because today most
of the tribes ever contacted live in
south america deep in the amazon
rainforest brazil which with its west
territory contains almost all of these
peoples boasts a range of 77 to 80 foot
tribes a data impossible to verify the
number of indigenous people currently
living in brazil who have never come
into contact with technologically
advanced men would range from a minimum
of six hundred to a maximum of about one
thousand many of these live in the
western states of mato grosso rondonia
and agree further south however in the
peruvian forest it's not uncommon to
encounter this warning sign do not try
to contact indigenous people do not give
them clothes or food do not photograph
them because they might see the camera
as a weapon in both peru and brazil
illegal logging poses a huge risk to
indigenous people a risk that not only
takes away vital portions of land from
indigenous people but also seriously
endangers the lives of the inhabitants
themselves the brazilian government has
repeatedly organized first contact
expeditions to track down the tribes
following the maxim of thought that
knowing where they are is the best way
to protect them funai the brazilian
government agency that deals with
indigenous issues has as its main
purpose to protect the tribes in the
amazon basin with frequent flyovers to
check their movements or to keep them
away from illegal invasions by brazilian
loggers it can sometimes happen in
brazil that the contacts are the result
of the will of the indigenous people
themselves
presence of isolated india's generates
panic at the border headlined this
brazilian newspaper the fact that
indigenous people make contact with
foreigners would not be dictated by a
desire to trade but by fear
in fact through people who spoke a
language similar to their own the
language of the panama group in 2014 a
group of indigenous people from the
state of akri the yawanawa claimed to
have been subjected to violent attacks
by loggers and cocaine traffickers
moreover according to survival
international the yawanawa literally the
people of the wild boar didn't stumble
upon the quote-unquote foreign
brazilians by accident actually these
tribes always know exactly where to go
they know the territory perfectly and
most likely know the outside world much
better than ordinary people think this
aspect goes against a typical cliche
namely the fact that peoples like the
ioa live unknowingly in a bubble
wilderness
not realizing that their little corner
of the world is actually part of a much
larger hall dominated by other human
beings the mistake we civilized people
make is to see the world like a video
game like civilization for example where
everything starts with attached hut and
the rest of the map is just fog-a-war
however history can teach us something
over the centuries and even decades past
local tribes have been enslaved by
foreigners european or otherwise since
the arrival of whites in the americas
indigenous peoples have learned to fear
men with technological tools and have
passed this message of warning from
generation to generation through oral
accounts in the 60s and 70s brazil then
saw the amazon as an abandoned place in
need of development an indigenous people
who opposed this progress were given
little or no warning before their homes
were bulldozed to the ground by
multinationals or by the government
itself
consider the massacres carried out up to
and throughout the 70s by natural rubber
scavengers against the sintalarga tribe
in motogrosso and rondonia from their
helicopters the scavengers dropped
sticks of dynamite on the villages to
drive out the natives with all the
consequences we can imagine also in the
brazilian state of brandon one single
man often referred to as the last of his
tribe still lives in a buffer zone a
patch of forest bordered voluntarily by
the government his people were killed by
ranchers many years ago when the
government managed to get on the man's
trail in 1996
the exploration team was met with a bow
and arrow as always and just like in his
case another tribe reduced to the bone
is the akunsu the accounts to live in a
territory demarcated by the brazilian
government in the state of rondonia the
brazilian government had the fabulous
idea of building an highway around their
plot br 364 the region was thus occupied
by timber companies landowners and
cattle ranchers in 1995 funai discovered
that the ranchers themselves had taken
over the yakuntu's lands slaughtering
almost all of their members and raising
homes to hide the murder to date only
five hakunsu are still alive not that
the situation is any rosier in other
south american nations in 2007 peru's
then president olan garcia became a
denialist promoter claiming that the
moscow hero were nothing more than a
fiction created by environmentalists to
pose oil exploration in the area
unfortunately peru has always been
courted by multinational oil companies
and today more than 70 percent of peru's
amazon territory is divided into various
oil concessions many of which were part
of those parcels controlled by
indigenous people they call it land
grabbing but land grabbing is a vast
phenomenon which does not only affect
south american territories and would
need specific investigation even today
we westerners are guilty of land
grabbing
all over the world
in the early 80s charles exploration in
peru led to contact with the nahua
reserve within a few years 50 percent of
the nahua would die some from violence
some from disease
the other major threat to peruvian
peoples are illegal loggers many of whom
go after mahogany known as red gold
mahogany possesses a much higher price
on the global market than any other
types of wood and so the question became
why don't we take a little trip to the
indigenous forests reaching this
material in the late 90s the situation
evolved to such an extent that it caused
a real red gold fever driven by a desire
to get rich loggers forced contact with
the murunawa tribe causing a similar
misfortune to what happened to the
yanomami in northern brazil on the
border with venezuela with the
difference that the curse of the
yanomami was gold the real gold the gold
sold by the garimperos
for thousands of muronawa the rush for
red gold was disastrous half the
population was decimated by colts flu
and respiratory infections with many
thanks from the logging companies the
peruvian government has always denied
the existence of tribes like the
moronawa yet satellite photos footage
and interviews blight
[Music]
many of these peoples are thus faced
with a difficult choice avoid contact at
all costs or risk death from disease and
violence diseases precisely because of
the low immune defenses that indigenous
people have not developed over the
centuries are the main cause of death
simply put we are now witnessing what
happened at the time of the great
explorations in the 16th century to the
indias of the new world or perhaps we
can say that the slaughter of latin
america never ended a sadly exemplary
case occurred in 1987 when a group of
missionaries the new tribe's mission
made contact with the zoe tribe in
brazil before they met the white men the
zoe had no diseases within a year of
first contact with them half of the zoe
population had died of disease
also the new tribe's mission in paraguay
organized the kind of manhunt against
the ayurvedo toto because of the tribe
the only virgin tribe in south america
living outside the amazon basin
in essence they were forcibly taking
indigenous people and removing them from
where they belonged so that they could
start large-scale deforestation works
and set up farming and ranching camps
this video by survival international is
worth a thousand words
to counter these abuses convention 169
on indigenous and tribal peoples was
drifted in 1989 by the un
ratified by 23 nations the convention
aims to protect fundamental rights for
the survival of indigenous people
including their right to land tenure and
self-determination and to date this is
the only instrument that protects these
tribes on paper from discrimination and
violence but as is often the case a
single convention cannot suffice and
governments that even sign it end up
ignoring its content
now without necessary lapsing into the
myth of the good savage these
hunter-gatherers are a remnant of our
past a millennial past
south american tribes unlike the
sentinelese do not live on an island
sheltered from modern society
today in every nook and cranny of the
world's largest forest
and eventually we too will witness the
extinction of the last tribe ever
contacted
see you when i recover